Veamos si podemos multiplicar 9 x 0.6. Otra forma
de escribir esto es que queremos calcular 9 x 0.6,
lo escribiré así 0.6, queremos calcular el
resultado de esto. Los invito a pausar el video
e intentar resolverlo por su cuenta. Les daré una
pequeña pista: 0.6 es lo mismo que 6 ÷ 10. Sabemos
que si tenemos un 6, que podríamos escribir
como 6.0, y tuviéramos que dividirlo entre 10,
esto sería equivalente a mover el punto
decimal una posición hacia la izquierda,
entonces 6 ÷ 10 = 0.6, estamos moviendo el punto
decimal una posición hacia la izquierda. Supongo
que lo intentaron. Lo que voy a hacer es usar esto
que escribimos aquí para reescribir lo que estamos
intentando multiplicar, entonces 9 x 0.6 es lo
mismo que 9 x 0.6 = 6 ÷ 10. En esta expresión
que tenemos aquí podríamos empezar dividiendo 6 /
10, con lo que obtendríamos 0.6, y se convertiría
en este problema. O podríamos resolver 9 x 6 en
primer lugar; entonces calculemos 9 x 6 y luego
lo dividiremos entre 10, que ya sabemos cómo
hacerlo, se trata de mover el punto decimal.
Entonces podríamos escribir 9 x 6, y sabemos que
es igual a 54, esto de aquí es igual a 54. Ahora,
para llegar a esta expresión tenemos que dividir
entre 10 -tenemos que dividir entre 10-, ¿y qué
pasa cuando dividimos algo entre 10? Hemos visto
esto en videos anteriores porque esto es así,
de esto se trata la notación decimal,
cada posición representa 10 veces más
que la posición de la derecha o cada posición
representa 1/10 de la posición de la izquierda,
de modo que 54 ÷ 10, esto va a ser igual a,
podríamos empezar con 54 y pondremos un 0 aquí,
después del punto decimal. Cuando dividimos
entre 10 es equivalente a desplazar el punto
decimal hacia la izquierda. Esto va a ser igual
5.4, y esto debería tener sentido: 5 x 10 = 50,
0.4 x 10 = 4, así que tiene sentido que 54 ÷ 10
sea igual a 5.4. Entonces esto que tenemos aquí es
igual a 5.4, y esto es lo mismo que acá, es igual
a 5.4. Fíjense que el 9 x 6 = 54, 9 x 0.6 = 5.4.
Ahora podemos ver un pequeño patrón aquí: entre
estos dos números tenía uno a la derecha del punto
decimal, cuando calculo su producto, digamos
que ignoramos el decimal y sólo decimos 9 x 6,
obtenemos 54, pero luego tengo que dividir entre
10 para tener en cuenta el decimal. Tenemos que
considerar que este no era un 6 eran 6 décimas,
así que aquí tenemos un número a la derecha del
punto decimal. Y quiero que pensemos si esto
es un principio general. ¿Podemos simplemente
contar el número total de dígitos a la derecha
de los puntos decimales y luego nuestro producto
va a tener la misma cantidad de dígitos a la
derecha del decimal? Dejaré que lo piensen.